last week we established that Coors is
more misunderstood than full-on monster
and today we're diving a bit deeper
we'll be learning about two types of
Korres requests and configuration as you
might remember we left our heroes as
they narrowly avoided a Korres error and
now they must learn to differentiate
between the different types of Korres
requests there are two types of course
requests simple and preflighted a simple
request can be initiated directly that
simple a preflighted request must send a
preliminary pre-flight request to the
server to get permission before the
primary requests can proceed that is the
client has to ask and the server has to
give the green light before the data can
be served
there are several circumstances under
which request is preflighted it uses
methods other than get ahead or post it
uses the post method with a content type
other than these types or it sets custom
headers for example if your app uses put
to ensure idempotent requests this
request would need to be preflighted
let's look at what happens when a
browser makes a simple request to cloud
storage the browser adds origin header
to the request the origin header
contains as you might have guessed the
origin of the resource seeking to share
the other domains resources cloud
storage compares the HTTP method of the
request like get or post and the value
of the origin header to the methods and
origins information in the target cloud
storage bucket scores configuration to
see if there are matches if there are
cloud storage origin includes the access
control allow origin header and it's
response the access control allow origin
header contains the value of the origin
header from the initial request the
browser then receives the response and
checks to see if the access control
allow origin value matches the domain
specified in the original request if
they do match the request succeeds if
they don't match or if the access
control allow origin header is
not present in the response the request
fails a preflighted request performs
some additional steps first before
following the same steps in a simple
request first the browser sends an
options request containing the requested
method and requested headers of the
primary request the server responds back
with the values of the HTTP methods and
headers allowed by the targeted resource
if any of the method or header values in
the pre-flight request aren't in the set
of methods and headers allowed by the
targeted resource the request fails and
the primary request isn't sent if the
method or header values are included the
request continues like a simple Korres
request once again this is a true bite
of the full course meal so make sure you
check out the documentation to learn
some more but let's talk about how you
configure cores for cloud storage cloud
storage allows you to set cores
configuration at the bucket level only
you can set the course configuration for
a bucket using the gsutil command-line
tool the XML API or the JSON API let's
look at setting up cores configuration
with gsutil
first I need a cores JSON document
here's an example this JSON document
explicitly allows cross-origin get and
post requests from origin 1 example.com
but not head it may include the content
type response header then I set the
course policy of the bucket to the JSON
document to remove the cores
configuration of a bucket the GS util
command is the same the difference is
that the cores JSON document is empty
now you know a bit more about cores as
well as how to set the cores
configuration for a cloud storage bucket
if you want to know even more about
cloud storage and cores check out the
links in the description don't forget to
subscribe give us a like and tell us
what you want to learn about Google
Cloud storage thanks for joining us for
this quick byte of cloud storage we'll
see you next time
[Music]